amélie non pas pour les législatives
soyez un petit peu de jeunesse est un
petit peu de dynamisme dans cette
station charles autres settini 31 ans
est officiellement candidate dans la
première circonscription des yvelines
nouvelle expérience pour cette
versailles et sans mandat qui s'est
engagé politiquement pour lutter contre
le retour de nicolas sarkozy en 2015
après la question qu'on peut se poser
c'est mais pourquoi le parti socialiste
parce que j'ai toujours été socialiste
j'ai toujours voté à gauche c'est le
parti socialiste ont fait trop présente
mais valeur donc la justice sociale
l'écologie le partage et c'est vraiment
s'en fait qu'ils mara qui m'a intéressée
à aller vers ce parti et puis c'est un
parti qui a une base militante qui est
importante et qui a engagé la première
circonscription un choix du coeur sur la
jeune socialiste qui a grandi et fait
ses études sur le territoire le
parachutage non merci je pense que je
pense qu'on va on va ceux-ci pas
possible pour comprendre ce qui se passe
dans un territoire il faut connaître
certes il faut y vivre moi je la versa y
j'ai fait mes études à montigny le
bretonneux
donc pourquoi la première
circonscription parce que c'est chez moi
tout simplement
ses principaux axes de campagne
l'écologie avec notamment la défense de
la cause animale et la protection des
catégories défavorisées
c'est vraiment que comment comment nous
aujourd'hui en tant que citoyen on peut
se réapproprier notre vie politique
comment on peut faire que tous ensemble
on puisse vraiment avancer et créer un
futur désirable c'était la petite phrase
de benoît
c'est comme pour présenter son programme
aux électeurs charlotte rossetti
n'hésite pas à les rencontrer sur les
marchés et les brocantes et savoir
comment ils veulent être représentés
pouvait pas le deviner
donc si vous n'allez pas à leur contact
vous fait pas savoir ce qu'ils veulent
en tout simplement c'est eux les ba
censées eux qu'on représente donc si
vous n'allez pas sur le terrain si vous
n'êtes pas à leur contact
ça pas vraiment grand intérêt si
charlotte rossetti ni ne partira pas
favorite lors de cette élection dernière
présidentielle benoît hamon a réalisé
que 5,34 % des suffrages à versailles
est un peu moins de 10% à montigny le
bretonneux
la femme politique devra notamment
batailler contre la liste heller udi
mené par françois-xavier bellamy
remplaçant du député sortant françois de
mazières et le candidat de la république
en marche didier baichère cette liste de
candidats n'est pas encore définitive